Chân trang em ăn giành sang hiệu áo qua khu ạ khu ạ khu ạ xin nè
Có nguyên hình là thủ học sinh chương chung hoặc của thương truyền trát bự châu,
nghe ăn, tương dành nhiều dài thương chung nước và phức tế,
trong đó có tấm vý trường đồng bối lý vị bịch bật lý châu au nha ngàn tương chạm bự chín.
Sau nhiều dự định khi các thúc mi hài nằm chú hoặc phu thông,
bình có ý định lý xu học, sau đó nột gân và hợp khu ạ xin nèo,
và chúng tỉnh ngã ngàn tương chăm hai người.
Dù gặp nhiều khó khăn chinh đất khách,
nhưng bằng những khô khăn phần nỗi lực không biết về mọi,
đình đã thích nghiệp với cái khó,
miếng mạnh, hoài xin mong đổi,
anh đã đẹp chung mình rất cao là bụng về chiến chinh nằm.
Nhận được xa thường, hành rõiq, ở sớt xe et,
sánh chương xin viên có nếu chung mình học tập xe,
hương hành ngàn tý thật mấy tính.